all right tonight President Trump is on
a complete tear by continuing to keep
his promises and enact the agenda that
you the American people voted for in
November 2016 the DHS secretary
Kirsten Nielsen she made a major
announcement earlier today about
President Trump's plan to secure the
southern border here's what she said the
president has directed the National
Guard personnel be deployed to the
southern border the Department of
Defense's you know has long supported
the efforts of DHS to protect our
nation's borders this includes ongoing
counter-narcotics missions
infrastructure construction persistent
surveillance operations training and
aerial support throughout the western
hemisphere the Department of Defense is
a longtime partner of the Department of
Homeland Security and I thank them for
their support
while plans are being finalized it's our
expectation that the National Guard will
deploy personnel in support of CBP's
border security mission and tonight we
have learned that President Trump has
signed the proclamation to send the
National Guard to the southern border
now the president he deserves a lot of
credit because if Congress if they're
not gonna lift a finger to solve the
problem then he is going to take the
steps as commander-in-chief and do it on
his own which he now has now before the
liberal media all you left us out there
start losing your collective minds over
the National Guard being deployed at the
southern border with all due respect we
will educate you there is already
precedence for all of this both George W
Bush and Barack Obama they actually did
the exact same thing and president
Trump's tough rhetoric calling for
Mexico to disband this caravan as you
see of asylum seekers heading for the US
border that's also working now according
to reports more than a thousand person
caravan has now fallen apart leaders of
the group are now saying they will no
longer head for America's southern
border now this is the start of good
news for the president look at this a
brand new Rasmussen poll his approval
rating is now 51 percent which is higher
than Barack Obama's during the exact
same time in his presidency he was only
a 46% and he got reelected but the
liberal media probably won't be telling
you that tonight they're too busy
orchestrating an onslaught
any negative story that they possibly
can find obsessing over Oh stormy
Daniels and Trump Russia collusion
Russia Russia Russia that doesn't exist
now there's also a fake news CNN poll
this is pretty amazing
we chose president Trump making major
gains with four key groups he's gained
eight points with man since February
five points with younger voters nine
points with middle-aged voters and he's
up by 10 points with college graduates
now here's what's so interesting about
these polls just imagine if the
president wasn't constantly under attack
from a media that wants to destroy him
imagine if Robert Muller and his team of
Democratic donors weren't carrying out
their never-ending witch-hunt only think
the president's poll numbers would be a
lot higher if a majority of the country
wasn't being fed an endless stream of
outright lies propaganda distortion and
misinformation now despite all that
President Trump he's just rolling along
doing his job every day the job that you
elected him to do look at this
manufacturing this is good news by the
way for the media to be so successful
and their attacks against Trump the kind
of cheering against the country
succeeding look at this
the strongest in three years ADP Moody's
Analytics they are now saying that two
hundred and forty-one thousand jobs
created in March and that's on top of
the record low unemployment levels that
we now have over three million jobs
created since Donald Trump selected and
by the way the lowest unemployment
numbers ever for african-americans and
Hispanic Americans look at this home
equity at a record level five point four
trillion dollars the president is also
taking a big step this is amazing
nobody ever reports it to make health
care more affordable for everybody and
getting around some of the devastating
Obamacare mandates is an op-ed in USA
Today explains how the Trump
administration has now set to lay out a
new rule they're about to implement this
it will lower the cost create choices by
extending expanding Association health
plans now these plans allow businesses
and trade associations to come together
buy health insurance plans in bulk that
saves a ton of money and by the way a
huge development you get more
care for less money and the president
also is taking steps to reduce the bloat
remember that 1.3 trillion dollar
omnibus spending bill that nobody liked
well thank god he is now he reluctantly
signed it now this is the bill that the
president threatened to veto but
remember he was forced to kind of sign
it because Congress well they left town
they're too lazy
well now the White House is looking into
using what is known as the impoundment
Control Act it's a law from 1974 it
gives the president the authority to
cancel spending already approved by
Congress by the way they only need 51
votes in the Senate Mitch Congress would
have 45 days to approve the President's
request to cut from the massive spending
bill again he's keeping a promise let's
hope that happens then on top of all of
this just take a look at the side of
your screen you'll never see this in the
media a list of just some of the
presidents many accomplishments during a
short time in office
I remember the Heritage Foundation they
did a study the president's first year
they found he has already accomplished
64% of his agenda which by the way is
higher than Ronald Reagan's 49% at the
same time in his presidency these are
real tangible achievements that help The
Forgotten men and women that voted in
November of 2016 that the liberal media
will never talk about because they never
want to give the president credit for
anything and as we've been explaining
President Trump is just on fire and it's
time for congressional Republicans to
follow suit time to get a backbone time
to keep their promises no more waiting
around let's see what happens in 2018
it's time for members of the GOP keep
their word keep their promises and that
means they should build this southern
wall they should keep the seven-year
promise to repeal and replace Obamacare
you know things that they all said and
promise when they were campaigning now
here's what's gonna happen if
Republicans don't keep their promises
Democrats are gonna try to
systematically undo every single one of
those accomplishments we'll put them
back on the screen Nancy Pelosi is
already threatened that she's gonna try
and repeal the tax cuts that benefit 90%
of Americans by the way you keep going
Nancy good job don't stop I want you to
stay on message so it's up to
congressional Republicans to show some
backbone some spine and actually fight
for the President's agenda that you
voted for now former House Oversight
Committee Chairman jason Chaffetz now
he's gonna join us in a few minutes he's
out with a list of ten things that
Congress should be doing right now in
the article Chaffetz suggests Congress
should explain and clarify the conflicts
of interest on special council Muller's
team I don't think there is an
explanation they should formally demand
the appointment of a second special
prosecutor with the power to prosecute
he lists call FISA Court judges before
Congress to offer public testimony they
were all lied to call Attorney General
Jeff Sessions to testify about
outstanding congressional subpoenas hold
hearings on securing our borders
fortifying them with a wall and then
pass legislation allowing the President
to reallocate funds from the DoD and of
course Oakland Mayor Libby Schaaf she
should be called to testify Facebook's
Mark Zuckerberg and Twitter's Jack
Dorsey they should be called to testify
about their speech suppression practices
especially against conservatives so
Zuckerberg will testify before lawmakers
next week about Cambridge analytics
Congress by the way should make an
effort to reform the broken budget
process they should give states the
opportunity to vote on whether Congress
should be subject to balancing the
federal budget and finally the Senate
should refuse to recess until every
single one of the president's appointees
have been voted on Mitch time to work
anyway congressman Chaffetz will be here
in a minute but first we have bought
breaking news tonight house Intel
Committee Chairman Devin Nunez he is
sent a letter to the Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosenstein and the FBI
director Christopher ray now Nunez is
blasting the repeated stonewalling by
the Department of Justice which is being
led by Rosenstein in refusing
continually to hand over documents that
have been subpoenaed by Congress
remember Rosenstein is the guy that ran
into Paul Ryan's office back in January
at the last hour begging speaker Ryan to
block congressman Nunez request for
documents about all the FISA abuses and
the dossier we wouldn't have learned
that had Paul Ryan capitulated without
those documents and never would have
been in Nunez
memo and we would not know about any of
the massive scandals that we are talking
about every night unfolding like the
FISA abuse lying to judges to get a
warrant to spy on a trump campaign
associate in that case Carter page Rod
Rosenstein why does he want to keep all
of this a secret why does he want to
protect all his corrupt friends but now
after months of obstructing chairman
Nunez demanding answers and by the way
newness has been asking for documents
some go back to August of 2017 rod hand
the documents over to the American
people that's how ridiculous this entire
process is and Nunez is now requesting
the DOJ do their job and of course
Congress has their job we have checks
and balances we have co-equal branches
of government the DOJ turned over the
unredacted version of an FBI memo
related to the bureau's opening of the
Russia investigation new NASA set a
deadline
April 11th now given what we've seen
from Rosenstein you know it's probably
going to be a long time before the house
Intel committee gets to see this the
level of obstruction and protection the
incestuous nature of the relationships
this is beyond disgraceful Rosenstein
has done everything possible that he can
do to prevent Congress from doing their
job which is oversight they have a
constitutional not only right but duty
to do so so tonight it's time for rod
Rosen scenes to stop hiding the truth
from the American people now his boss is
the Attorney General jeff Sessions and
Jeff Sessions rightly said last week
that he's angry at the slow pace that
these documents are being turned over
well you know what well the Attorney
General needs to do something about it
if the Attorney General is angry he
needs to take action and force the
deputy AG Rosenstein to do his job and
if Rosen scene doesn't want to then he
needs to go because that is how our
government is supposed to work
Congress needs to be able to get answers
on behalf of you we now see corruption
at the highest levels of government and
then you got a corrupt media well
they're a major denial that's they're
beside themselves over reports that
President Trump is not currently Oh let
me repeat not a toy
get of the special counsel Robert Muller
is corrupt investigation now despite
this new development of media is
desperate they're holding out hope
they're on their knees they're praying
to God that somehow someway
Robert Muller will still find a way to
make Donald Trump the target and go
after the president now think through
this if that ever happened is that good
for the country is that good for the
Forgotten men and women of the country
does that create jobs does that get
people out of poverty and off of food
stamps No
does it keep us safer no do they seem to
care no take a look the subject just
means someone of interest to the grand
jury but it can also mean someone who's
on the road to being charged with a
crime it's a big deal to be some under
criminal investigation by the FBI
particularly if you're president of the
United States
so certainly being a subject they
shouldn't be cracking on you open any
champagne in the White House if he's the
subject of an investigation a target is
somebody they're going to indict and the
president by the policy cannot be
indicted so it's a little vague what
their meaning and it may be to make mr.
Trump relax if someone walked in my
office and said I was a subject of a
multi-year criminal investigation led by
former FBI director Robert Moore I'd wet
my pants a non-target letter isn't worth
the paper that it's printed on because
the prosecutor can just decide two days
after he writes the letter that he wants
to now he's made it he made up his mind
to charge you he can't help but think
and maybe it's strategic I could tell
him he's a subject he likes being the
subject what we're gonna discuss with
some people who have experience in this
just how often that occurs if there's a
little bit of shading of it when they're
just on the verge of switching you into
target they still say or subject they've
been saying this for 18 months the media
is not even trying to hide their bias
they want the president impeach they're
not gonna stop till it happens but
here's the thing the media's been
flat-out wrong about everything
regarding the Russia investigation now
constitutional law expert Jonathan
Turley Democrat is scolding the
abusively biased media and a new op at
he's put out here's the headline when
will the media accept the Trump is not a
criminal target they'll totally blast
the media
promising for over a year bombshell
bombshell bombshell smoking gun it's all
coming here's what he told martha
maccallum earlier tonight take a look we
went through a long period where people
talked about collusion as if there was
some federal crime called collusion and
then they had morphed into obstruction
and then it morphed into things like you
know campaign finance violations or
other issues all these crimes of
elements they have case precedent you
have to satisfy those and where you and
I have talked that there are areas that
should be of a great concern for
president Trump these these crimes have
not strengthened over time you know when
Co me before Comey was fired he said he
told Trump that he was not a target of
that investigation it appears that
nothing has changed after over a year it
would think that after a year of
conducting a witch hunt that Muller
might have something on President Trump
but so far that does not appear to be
the case not to mention by the way this
is something the media refuses to accept
as constitutional law Professor Alan
Dershowitz is explaining oh this is
rougher the media to handle collusion is
not a crime